you're solely we need to talk about palm
oil it's in everything from ice cream -
pizza - lipstick - soap palm oil is a
versatile oil with a long shelf life
it's the cheapest vegetable oil to
produce and it's in high demand sourcing
all this palm oil though has a big
impact on our earth the oil palm tree is
native to Central and West Africa but
its biggest producer is Indonesia
tropical rainforests span Indonesia and
the climate is ideal for palm oil
production Borneo is the third largest
island in the world and is home to
orangutangs pygmy elephants the boss's
monkeys and many more species the
fastest method to clear land for palm
wall is to rip out forest and burn
whatever is left according to Harvard
and Columbia researchers fires led to a
hundred thousand premature deaths in
Indonesia in 2015 on Sumatra an island
in Indonesia entire villages have been
bulldozed by palm oil companies leaving
people without homes and relying on
government aid from 1999 to 2015 almost
150,000 Bornean orangutan died from
trees being cut down in their habitat
and hunting according to nasa increased
destruction of forests in Borneo
contributed to the largest annual
increase in carbon emissions in the last
2,000 years it was estimated that global
consumption of palm oil would reach 72
million tonnes in 2018 which equals
about 20 pounds of palm oil per person
palm oil can be found in over 50% of the
packaged products Americans consume so
what do we do read the ingredients on
the things you buy and avoid
irresponsibly produce palm oil products